ich freue mich heute hier sprechen zu
können zum auftrag des panels anwärters
meeting global challenges
vor wenigen tagen war ich vor ort in
lebensnah der kontakt linie in der ost
ukraine und ich stand hinter mir im
rücken ein zerstörtes haus und rechts
neben ihr ein schulhof und wie jede
mutter dachte ich an meine kinder die
morgens zur schule springt ganz
unbedarft in großer hektik manchmal und
hatte zugleich die mitte vor augen die
das genau an diesem ort nicht tun
nämlich nicht einfach mal so neben
selbst nebenbei selbstverständlich kann
jederzeit mit der großen sorge weil die
gewalt allgegenwärtig ist und real wie
real diese sorge ist dass wird klar wenn
wir hören dass es gestern hunderte
verletzungen des waffenstillstandes
gegeben hat an einem friedlichen alltag
für kinder ist an diesem ort nicht zu
denken
das zeigt worum es wirklich geht wenn
wir über minsk reden es ist nicht nur
ein verhandlungs format links ist auch
nicht nur ein technischer begriff
sondern es geht um menschliche
sicherheit darum ob familien kinder in
der mitte europas in der mitte unseres
europas sicher und in frieden aufwachsen
können heute das müssen wir so deutlich
sagen droht ein neuer krieg mitten in
unserem europa russland spricht mit
seinem truppenaufmarsch eine absolut
inakzeptabel drohungen aus gegenüber der
ukraine aber auch gegenüber uns ein und
unser friedens architektur in europa
diese krise ist deswegen und da müssen
wir sehr genau beim fremming aufpassen
diese krise ist eine ukraine krise sie
ist eine russlandkrise
wir rufen daher russland eindringlich
auf seine truppen umgehend abzuziehen
erste signale und das erleben wir ja in
den letzten wochen und tagen immer
wieder erste signale waren ein
hoffnungsschimmer aber wir müssen jetzt
auch taten sehen denn die russische
drohung ist weiterhin real und genauso
real ist aber unsere gemeinsame antwort
wenn es zu einem russischen angriff auf
die ukraine käme dann hätte dies massive
konsequenzen für russland finanziell
politisch und wirtschaftlich
und wir haben eine noch
gleichlautende deutliche botschaft an
moskau wir wollen das nicht wir wollen
diese konsequenzen eigentlich gar nicht
wir wollen einen ernsthaften dialog über
sicherheit und frieden in unserem
gemeinsamen europa das ist in unser
aller interesse
und ja wir wollen das risiko von
eskalationen in europa minimieren was
denn sonst ja auch wir wollen
verlässlichkeit schaffen genau deswegen
haben wir in den letzten wochen als nato
staaten dazu substanzielle vorschläge
erarbeitet
die liegen jetzt in moskau auf dem tisch
und jeder zeit jede minute in diesem
moment gestern heute und morgen wollen
wir genau darüber reden aber was wir
nicht wollen und was wir auch nicht
können ist unsere gemeinsame richtete
sicherheitsarchitektur in frage zu
stellen
der gestrige antwortbrief von russischer
seite klingt zu meinem großen bedauern
aber genau danach
herr präsident putin lieber kollege
sergej lavrov und der streichung in
ihrem antwortschreiben das zur
bündnisfreiheit auch das prinzip gehört
das sicher nicht auf kosten anderer
gehen darf ja darauf haben wir uns
gemeinsam verständigt wir gemeinsam
haben uns darauf verständigt dass es
eine gemeinsame sicherheit ist die nicht
auf kosten anderer gehen darf zu diesen
grundsatz bekennen wir uns ausdrücklich
aber gerade deswegen müssen wir doch
über den truppenaufmarsch an der
ostukrainischen grenze sprechen der
natürlich auf kosten der ukraine geht
130 soldaten an der grenze das ist
schwer nicht als bedrohung zu verstehen
wer gemeinsam in sicherheit leben will
der droht einander nicht der gemeinsam
in sicherheit leben will der spricht am
verhandlungstisch über unsere gemeinsame
sicherheit
klar
klar und so ehrlich muss man auch sein
und wir werden jetzt tony blinken und
ich und viele viele andere
außenministerin und außenminister
verteidigungsminister diplomaten sie in
diesem raum wir werden immer wieder
gefragt jetzt geht das schon eine woche
wie lange soll das ganze dennoch dauern
vielleicht wochen vielleicht monate
verhandlungen sind meistens ein
verhandlungsmarathon mit rückschlägen
mit missverständnissen manchmal auch mit
fouls aber wer angst vor der strecke hat
und gar nicht erst antritt der hat schon
verloren
helsinki oder jalta so hat der
historiker timothy garton ash vor kurzem
die wahl umrissen vor der wir
europäerinnen und europäer jetzt stehen
die wahl also zwischen einem system
gemeinsamer verantwortung für sicherheit
und frieden das auf basis der grund akte
von helsinki und der charta von paris
steht die wir alle unterzeichnet haben
oder ein system der mächte rivalität und
einflusssphären für das die leiter
konferenz von 1945 stand für mich ich
glaube für alle hier im raum ist das die
entscheidende frage denn was hier für
uns europäern und die internationale
gemeinschaft zur debatte steht das ist
nicht nur die frage wie wir diese
aktuelle krise lösen es ist die frage
wie wir in zukunft für unsere
regelbasierte ordnung einstehe eine
ordnung die auf der charta der vereinten
nationen basiert auf den prinzipien von
selbstbestimmung der achtung von
freiheit und menschenrechten und dem
prinzip der internationalen
zusammenarbeit wie der generalsekretär
der vereinten nationen gerade hier so
eindringlich unterstrichen hat
funktioniert dieses prinzip noch oder
leben wir das ist der titel der heutigen
morgen und übermorgen konferenz oder
leben wir in einem zeitalter der
kollektiven depression es der
resignation und hilflosigkeit wie dieses
panel überschrieben ist lieber tony
blinken wir beide für in dieser tage
unzählige gespräche aber
was mich in diesen schwierigen zeiten
optimistisch stimmt ist genau das wissen
und die kraft unser transatlantischen
geschlossenheit die unfair
brüderlichkeit unseres bündnisses
und die stärke unserer liberalen
demokratien und deswegen ist meine
antwort ganz eindeutig auf die frage wo
wir gerade stehen hilflos oder nicht wir
sind nicht kollektiv hilflos im
gegenteil geschäfte unsere stärke aus
unserem gemeinsamen handelns wir haben
es alle gemeinsam in der hand ob wir
hilflos sind oder eben nicht
drei elemente sind dafür für mich
entscheiden entschlossenheit solidarität
und verlässlichkeit das gilt in der
russland krise aber es gilt eben auch
darüber hinaus
entschlossen sind wir mit blick auf die
maßnahmen die wir für den fall eines
vorgehens russlands gegen die ukraine
vorbereiten
diese sanktionen wären präsident los und
mit allen partnern abgestimmt und
vorbereitet
die als deutschland sind bereit selber
dafür einen hohen wirtschaftlichen preis
zu bezahlen deswegen liegen für mich
liegen für uns alle optionen auf dem
tisch auch nord stream zwei
solidarisch
solidarisch sind wir weil wir zur
territorialen integrität und
souveränität der ukraine stehen und ich
sage es hier sehr deutlich
solidarität heißt gerade in
drucksituationen klar zu sein über den
weg den ein land gehen will können nur
das land selbst und vor allen dingen
seine menschen entscheiden wir
verhandeln nicht über den kopf der
ukraine hinweg
[Applaus]
solidarität heißt dass wir die sorgen
unserer mittel und osteuropäischen
nachbarn ernst nehmen deswegen
verstärken wir gemeinsam unser nato
engagement
solidarität heißt aber auch und das ist
für mich wichtig außenpolitik ist nicht
nur
politik zwischen politikerinnen und
politikern nicht nur ein hin und her
pendeln zwischen hauptstädten sondern
bei der außenpolitik geht es um menschen
um unsere menschen und deswegen heißt
solidarität in der jetzigen situation
eben nicht nur solidarität mit kiew
sondern mit den menschen in der ukraine
und vor allen dingen denen menschen an
der kontakt linie dazu ist die osze
entscheiden deren beobachter dort unsere
augen und ohren sind wir müssen
gemeinsam sicherstellen dass sie ihre
arbeit effektiv ausüben können gerade
jetzt wo die gewalt um die kontakt linie
in den letzten 48 stunden dramatisch
zugenommen hat
dies ist jetzt einer der gefährlichsten
momente wo aus provokation und
desinformation eskalation werden kann
ich sage es klar und deutlich dieses
spiel machen wir nicht mit ganz im
gegenteil wir arbeiten mit aller kraft
an konstruktiven wegen aus der krise im
normandie format in der eu in der nato
und im sicherheitsrat jeder schritt in
richtung frieden ist mühsam wir ringen
um jeden millimeter
aber jeder millimeter ist besser als
keine bewegung und damit bin ich bei
meinem dritten verlässlichkeit in der
außenpolitik die auf klaren werten
basiert für die menschen in der ukraine
geht es um ihr recht auf freiheit ihr
recht selber über ihre zukunft
entscheiden zu können für uns alle geht
es um nicht weniger als den frieden in
europa und die frage ob wir unsere
regelbasierte ordnung verteidigen auch
wenn es hart auf hart kommt wir leben in
einer welt in der diese regelbasierte
ordnung nicht nur in osteuropa unter
druck gerät mit wachsenden
geopolitischen spannungen im wettbewerb
zwischen autoritären kräften und
liberalen demokratien wir sehen wenn wir
uns als liberale demokratien in diesem
wettbewerb zurückziehen dann werden
andere diese lücke füllen das erleben
wir mit privaten söldner gruppen oder
auch mit großen infrastrukturvorhaben in
afrika aber wir haben es auch erlebt in
europa in der eu als wir unsere lücke
der solidarität gelassen hatten bei
investitionen in stromnetze in autobahn
oder in digitale infrastruktur und noch
stärker haben wir es gesehen zu beginn
dieser pandemie bei der impfstoff
verteilung wenn andere rein gehen dann
passiert das oftmals nicht aus
altruistischen gründen sondern dahinter
steckt ein knallhartes geostrategisches
kalt kühlen
daher müssen wir aus meiner sicht als
liberale demokratien in den wettstreit
zwischen autoritären kräften und
liberalen demokratischen werten nicht
nur deutlich sagen was andere falsch
machen sondern durch unser handeln
zeigen wofür wir gemeinsam ein stehen
die gemeinsame erholung nach der
pandemie das war's der us-präsident
beiden und auch die vereinten aktionen
unter diesem schönen label bild bag
besser definiert haben dass es auch eine
riesenchance eine riesenchance für uns
alle für die internationale
zusammenarbeit ist beim weg aus der
krise gemeinsam wirklich richtig zu
machen für die ukraine aus dem weg aus
der krise heraus zu investieren
gemeinsam zu investieren in
infrastruktur aber eben auch gemeinsam
zu investieren aus dem weg der pandemie
und daher wird die deutsche g7
präsidentschaft die wir dieses jahr ja
auch immer haben vor allen dingen dieses
motto haben wir zeigen was unsere werte
sind wir zeigen dass internationale
zusammenarbeit stärker ist als
nationaler alleingänge und das eine
ordnung auf grundlage des
internationalen rechts eines fairen
miteinanders der demokratie und
menschenrechte mittelfristig mehr bringt
als nationale abschottung und dazu
zählen für mich beim stichwort
menschenrechte und ja das sage ich auch
als erste außenministerin meines landes
nach 151 jahren dazu zählen für mich
auch die frauenrechte frauenrechte sind
der gradmesser für den zustand liberaler
demokratien
[Musik]
wir erleben dass wir erleben das
weltweit das sage ich auch als deutsch
als europäerin
wir erleben dass weltweit nicht nur
anderen ländern sollen wir haben zu
beginn der pandemie auch in unserem land
gelebt dass das beschwören des starken
mannes oftmals geben nicht der
erfolgreichste weg ist und wir sehen
weltweit dass das beschwören des einen
einzigen starken mannes mit dem
erstarken von autoritären kräften und
mit einem abbau von demokratischen
rechten einhergeht und daher das war
einer der schönsten die ich aus der
kontakt wieder von der kontakt linie
mitgenommen habe da haben nämlich einige
der mütter gesagt erst wenn frauen
sicher sind sind alle sicher und das ist
unsere aufgabe
in dem sinne bin ich überzeugt dass
unsere globalen herausforderung wie
klimakrise sie haben das angesprochen
1,5 grad fahrt die panini bekämpfung
nicht einer alleine sondern nur wir alle
gemeinsam lösen können mit einem klaren
wertekompass wir müssen uns bewusst
machen wir sind in einer wirklich
schwierigen krise gerade hier in europa
gerade hier als transatlantiker nach
dieser krise wird diese welt eine andere
sein es ist an uns wir haben es in der
hand jetzt ist die stunde für das recht
und den frieden in europa einzustehen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]